t'inquiète elle voit plus très
bien e non merci ça me fait
pisser a des trucs qui P société il y a
des règles des bonnes manières quoi non
mais c'est quoi ce boule tu as dit quoi
toi moi rien du tout je t'assure
j'arrête les conneries je vais me calmer
non mais quel
[Musique]
cul c'est mon neveu il est un peu beau
gosse mal
poli
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est Samana et je vais bien
m'occuper de votre engent et du mien
aussi
quoi il faut qu'on se tire d'ici le plus
vite possible oh tuas un
plan une tête de prier signe de Jeff
PAC Jeff manacok à la poursuite de
Jean-Marc ça sort mercredi au cinéma ça
ça c'est bien c'est du bon c'est du très
bon on va voir un petit extrait quand tu
découvres que Jean-Marc parle oui c'est
vrai bah c'est le film ah je c oui
regarde
regarde chercher quoi bah moi du
con ça va
Martine tu
tu ouais
articule tu tu B fouilles Martine on
comprend rien mais tu parles ouais et si
tu me tripotes je peux aboyer
aussi non c'est pas possible il y a des
piles c'est ça mais oui c'est ça bravo
capitaine Marlot et son sont où dans ton
cul mais un coup tu vas
clignoter reviens
Martine à la poursuite de Jean-Marc ça
sort mercredi au cinéma g chez ST fan
c'est le divertissement idéal qu'on
cherchait pour les fêtes c'est avoir en
famille on rit de bout en bout et ce qui
est génial c'est votre complicité ou pas
toujours entre vous deux mais ça ça
fonctionne super bien les courses
poursuites sont extraordinaires on
croirait un film américain et dans ma
bouche c'est un hommage et puis les gag
en série donc franchement on rit c'est
un super film gag en série c'est un truc
qu'on a pas
entendu Sée généralement quand tu as ça
c'est c'est mauvais
signe tout cas tu joues très
bien parce que c'est pas évident mais
sans rigonner tu vois on peut faire des
spectacles et le ciné autre chose j'en
ai fait les frais tu vois moi j'étais
moi j'étais c'est passé hier quoi oui
bah votre film il est passé hier c'est
lequel je tombé sur votre tronche hier
soirér je l'ai pas vu je l'ai pas vu je
l'ai pas vu et c'est vrai que c'est très
dur de de de jouer le le comédien tu
vois moi j'ai bah déjà tuattends
beaucoup c'est vrai que c'est dur le
cinéma tuattends tu vois des heures et
tout pour faire une scène de de 30
secondes moi j'en pouvais plus en Chine
là-bas j'ai passé 11 jours en Chine pour
r
tourner minutes non mais franchement non
mais c'est vrai on est parti en Chine et
tout c'est vrai que c'est long tu vois
moi c'est la télé tu vois c'est pas
pareil toi tuhabitude de faire
l'habitude de faire des trucs immédiat
30 secondes ouais c'est ça ouais non
c'était pas TR il fait tout en 30
secondes ça t' plus ou pas franchement
oua j'ai kiffé j'ai mais effectivement
c'est long c'est c'est un autre travail
que que le spectacle et puis aussi
d'essayer de faire rire sur un plateau
de cinéma alors qu'on a pas le droit de
rire c'est c'est c'est difficile donc il
a fallu que je fasse mon deuil des rire
déjà et après ouais j'ai kiffé et puis
avec PEF c'était génial aussi vraiment
vraiment j'adore ce mec et lui il t'a
suivi dans tous tes délires c'est ça
dans tous mes délires et puis surtout il
a il a Mané le film vraiment hy bien a
vraiment un aspect aussi poétique dans
le film que j'aime sur notre rencontre
et ça c'est vraiment pe qui a tout qui a
tout amené làdessus avec dev Cohen qui a
écrit le le scénario donc ououais je
leur do dev Cohen que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs que je viens de voir
j'embrasse fort j'embrasse Albert
également le producteur c'est ça non
Daniel Daniel oui [__] merde mais
parce que je l'appelle Albert dans dans
des
soirées bois de B au bois de Boulogne je
texliquerai normalement vous avez tous
vu le film puis que un lien vous a été
envoyé ou normal vous l'avez tous vu
ouais donc je vais faire le quiz de la
promo ok donc c'est très simple je vous
pose des questions voilà si vous donnez
une mauvaise réponse Jean-Marc vous dira
ce qu'il pense de vous d'accord ça vous
va répond
[Rires]
mal Jeff emprunte une Citroën GS à son
beau-père quelle est d'ailleurs c'est
une DS non c'est quoi c'est une
s pas de le dire et quelle est la
finition de cette voiture finition
Palace Atlas ou tanas c'est une finition
Palace is bah oui l'utom ça tu peux pas
nous dire ce que tu penses de lui mais
tu nous le diras quand même tout à
l'heure si tu veux k Jeff va-t-il
chercher pour son mariage ourriel et
Guillaume
[Applaudissements]
Janton sa mère ou sa grand-mère
grandmère grandmère non non mais je pas
demandé tu t'appelles benim alors
puisqu'il a répondu tu dis ce que tu
penses de cardos
connard grat c'est rigolo merci quelle
est la particularité de la lieutenant
qui traque Jeff et Jean-Marc Kelly par
que lui il a déjà elle est géniale
d'ailleurs cette actrice exactement elle
a une calviciie elle a une jambe de bois
ver euh elle a une jambe de bois non
dislui ce que tu penses d'elle elle a
une calviciie CALV euh je ne fa tâé non
non t'inquiète elle est gentille elle
l'air vénère non ouais toujours toujours
toujours mais elle est gentille conasse
voilà mais non lui c'est gratos lui
c'est rigolo en tout cas je vois que tu
les connais bien on regarde souvent hein
bah oui tu dis que des
conneries tu veux que je te dise tu veux
que je te dise dans ta France elle est
triste
[Applaudissements]
voilà pas
attendre qui joue le rôle du gendarme
qui contrôle Jeff et Jean-Marc Bruno
pomard avec les compages du SPIP PEF
elloun ouais c'est lui qui a d'ailleurs
réalisé le film je vais rester que
Daniel Moro tiens mamie qui est drotour
ou ça va ça va super radieuse ouais j'ai
adoré le film non mais c'est pas pour ça
que tu es radieuse ou c'est ta façon
d'être quoi tu tu as adoré le film en
donc tu pouras répondre à la question
ben je j'espère en tout cas pour qui
Jeff fait-il passer Jean-Marc auprès des
gens qu'il croise je donne même pas de
proposition euh son neveu son neveu
merde il y avait des
propositions ouais oui on l'a vu dans la
bande annonce en plus quelle phobie Jeff
a-t-il dans le film mundere il a la
phobie des interventions de
mundir ah ouais elle est mortelle celle
j'aime beaucoup j'adore il a peur des
marionnettes ou il a le vertige il a le
vertige c'est la C exactement bravo e
non ils sont bien bossés franchement
Géraldine Jean-Marc dit qu'il est
originaire de quelque part ou une île en
Floride une île des Antilles une île
flottante je souviens pas de ça ah si
bah vas-y ma chérie ah je l'insulte là
ouaisy vas-y ouais ça serait bien que tu
l'insultes un peu ouais préère tu
m'insultte tu préfèrees ouais
fasse euh voilà très bien c'était dans
c'était euh c'est dans une île en
Floride Okon oui où est-ce que Jeff se
fait Giler par une femme à cause de
Jean-Marc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gif où est-ce que Jeff se fait gifler
par une femme à cause de jean-mar dans
avion dans un train ou sur Moot qu'on a
vu dans complément d'enquête on l'a vu
dans un train ouais ouis exactement
bravo bien sûr on l'a vu dans la
bandeannonce et enfin question pour moi
dans quel film il y a une référence à un
film connu avec un accessoire que porte
Jean-Marc lequel c'est bien sûr le
masque danbal lecteur voilà merci donc
tu peux voilà tu peux
con répondu ouais j'avais envie c'est ah
oui j'ai bien répondu franchement allez
voir ce film ça sort mercredi Jeff tu
nous régales et je pense que ça va être
le film qui va cartonner le plus pendant
les vacances oui je voudrais dire aussi
c'est bien pour les parents aussi voilà
tout le monde peut y aller c'est
vraiment familial tout le monde les
parents les grand regarde m est allé
elle est allé avec elle est allé avec sa
mère et sa
grand-mère elles ont toutes kiffé
c'étaitre son dernier en plus oui est-ce
que vous avez des questions pour Jeff et
Jean-Marc allez-y ou moi juste j'ai aimé
parce que Jean-Marc en fait vous êtes
notre côté obscur c'estd qu'en fait
aujourd'hui on nose plus rien dire et
tout ça et on a envie d'avoir un
Jean-Marc dans notre besaceou dans notre
sac en disant [__] on aimerait dire ça
mais on peut pas dire ça donc il y a un
truc dans le film qui est très réussi et
à mon avis qui va vraiment cartonner du
coup je te regarde pas dans les yeux je
regarde jeanmc dans les yeuxou vois je
vois jeve tu vois moi le problème que
j'ai maintenant c'est que je suis toi et
Jean-Marc parce que je dis aussi des
trucs que dit Jean-Marc mainant j'ai
plus aucun filtre donc mais toi tu vois
c'est vra qu' y a plein de gens qui
aimeraient avoir un jean-marcou c'est
vrai c'est vrai Gill moi j'ai une
question vas-y euh vous avez connu les
plus grands animateurs Patrick Sébastien
vous avez travaillé avec ou connu
Patrick Sébastien Cyril Hanouna beaucoup
d'autres parmi tout Cuxa quel était le
plus gros
connard rigole tu je tu veux que je te
laisse réfléchir tu veux que je te
laisse réfléchir oui je veux bien mais
faut que je réponde moi non mais toi ou
Jean-Marc ah oui ah oui moi j'ai nom
attends alors tu dans un instant à tout
de suite pter on se retrouve à tout de
[Applaudissements]
suite